right now we're going to bring you more
of John Dickerson's interview with
President Trump they spoke inside the
Oval Office about the decisions the
president makes there it's all covered
in this extended interview you'll see
only on CBS this morning John Nora
thanks on his 100th day I spoke with the
president in the Oval Office we
discussed his relationship with former
President Barack Obama how he realized
the magnitude of the office and how he
uses the room every president makes the
Oval Office there's what have you done
to make this yours well a lot of things
we had these incredible flags including
the American flags and they were in
different rooms and they were always
being pushed around because they didn't
have enough room and I said how
beautiful the base the flags Army Navy
Marine Corps we have been just so
beautiful
just so beautiful the Coast Guard flag
over here and I said well let's see how
they look at the Oval Office
so the flags are up the picture of
Thomas Jefferson I put up the picture of
Andrew Jackson I put up because they
said his campaign and my campaign
intended to mirror each other so we did
a lot of actually we did a lot of work
it said so much it's a much different
look than it was previously
what would Fred try let's picture Fred
Trump arrest my father I have a one
coming of my mother what would even want
well he'd be very proud he was a
Brooklyn builder I learned a lot from
him it's a great guy good hard tough guy
but a good heart great heart and he'd be
very proud
you said the white house was like a
cocoon sometimes tell me about that well
I was very well known as you understand
prior to this but that was a different
type of that was a different world this
is something you are really in your own
little world
Secret Service they're phenomenal but
they are all over the place I mean they
are the real deal they're all over the
place if I wanted to get out drive my
car to a certain location and go do
something you can't do that anymore
haven't been able to do that for a long
period of time but all of that I
understand I guess I assumed that that
would happen if you won and most
importantly I think we're doing a very
good job and I enjoy it
tell me about what you see do a lot of
your work in here I do I'm here a lot
actually why in here and not other
places
I feel very warm toward the Oval Office
it's a great symbol also when I have
certain people that we want to negotiate
for instance I was negotiating to reduce
the price of the big fighter jet
contract
the f-35 which was totally out of
control I will save billions and
billions and billions of dollars and
calling from here and meeting here and
having meetings on that contract I think
gives you great additional power you
want another truth
so what other people have come in big
people from big companies they've been
to the White House 50 times in one case
I won't say who somebody you know very
well the head of a major major company I
said have you been to the White House
before yes 51 times I said oh good so
you've been to the Oval Office no I was
never brought to the Oval Office I said
come on I'll bring it to the Oval Office
the person came into the Oval Office and
started to cry this is a tough person by
the way came into the Oval Office and
started to cry now there's a person with
a magnificent office with beautiful
glass walls and everything else you
understand you've seen those offices
before but there is something very
special about this space if somebody's
going to behave like that in front of
you in here how do you know that people
aren't always just telling you what you
want to hear you mean with the tears is
it just there you know they see the
power of the White House and ailable
office and I think yes mr. president
hotels you know oh I think when it comes
to the Oval Office I think everybody
means that you know when I have foreign
leaders here no matter what country no
matter how big we had as a Chancellor
Merkel we have we have all they all come
here they still take notice at the Oval
Office right and they mean it but that's
I mean one of the worries about a
presidency is that everybody tells you
yes nobody helps you figure out where
your blind spots are so how do you how
do you find that I guess
one of those things in life you have to
be able to figure I've been figuring
that out anyway long before I got here
but some things you have to be able to
figure out but this is a special place
the White House is special the Oval
Office very special any other gadgets
you've gotten installed here since you
came well everyone thinks that this is
very ominous right here see this these
are phones these are very you know
secure phones but this is a very ominous
looking because of the red button what
does that get you well get you a Coke or
get you a Pepsi one of the other right
have to be any other Cola companies I
should mention right but it gets you
something but every time I press that
people worry right back to have fun with
people they'll be sitting down I change
the way it works I'll have people
sitting there used to be they never had
chairs that anybody can remember in
front of the desk but I've always done
it this way where I'm at the desk and I
have people here but usually they would
sit on the sofas but this is the
resolute desk it's a great desk with a
phenomenal history many great presidents
were behind this desk and then some
choose other desks they have about seven
desks that you can actually choose but I
like this this was FDR was Ronald Reagan
it was Kennedy there's some great
presidents behind this desk George W
Bush said they had reason the Oval
Office is around is there no corners you
can hide in well this truth to that
there's truth to that there are
certainly no corners and you look
there's a certain openness but there's
nobody out there you know there is an
openness but I've never seen anybody out
there actually as you could imagine but
he what he meant was it's all shoes back
to you I'm sure it does but I think
that's true anyway but it does there's
no question when did that hit you that
you're the magnitude of that of the
office and that idea that you were
regardless of what happened your name at
the buck stopped with you it's the
bigness of the office it's the bigness
of the transactions it's the bigness of
the deals you look at the order of
planes it's bigger than any order of
planes you look at aircraft carriers
that cost 10 billion and 12 billion
to build in submarines it costs five
billion dollars to build it's the
magnitude but most importantly you know
the decisions like when I made the
decision to go with Syria the 59
Tomahawk missiles unbelievable
technology we have unbelievable talent
but those are tough decisions those
aren't like decisions that I'm going to
buy a building online because it's human
lives killing people you're killing
people and you can kill the wrong people
too you know those things go off and
they end up in a town or they end up in
a city and you have another tragedy on
your hands so these decisions are
unbelievable but in terms of the
importance because it's human it's it's
it's killing I hate it but things have
to be done how do you learn that skill
who do you call to say what's it like is
nobody you can call did President Obama
give you any advice that was helpful
that you think wow he really was very
nice to me but after that we've had some
difficulties so it doesn't matter you
know words are less important to me than
deeds and you saw what happened with
surveillance and everybody saw what
happened with surveillance
Salty's how I thought that well you saw
what happened with surveillance and I
think that was inappropriate what does
that mean sir
you can figure that out you say like the
reason I asked as you said he would you
call him sick and bad look you can
figure it out yourself
he was very nice to me with words but
and when I was with him but after that
there has been no relationship but you
stand by that claim about I'm stand by
anything I just you can take it the way
you want
I think our sides have been proven very
strongly and everybody is talking about
it and frankly it should be discussed I
think that is a very big surveillance of
our citizens I think that's a very big
topic and it's a topic that should be
number one and we should find out what
the hell is going on I just wanted to
find out that you're either president
United States you said he was sick and
bad because he attempted to anyway you
can take it any way you want
but I'm asking you because you don't
want to do fake news I want to hear from
President wrong you don't have to ask
why not because I have my own opinions
you can have your own opinions but I
want to know your opinions you're the
in the united states it's enough thank
you thank you very much